so uh only one hour and 20 whatever
minutes left to go deja just sit real
tight
I've done teeth whitening once with a
white strip it didn't go well
I just imagined like this giant machine
is gonna like me like this I've actually
been told I have quite white teeth I
actually wore my retainer for the first
time in months last night in preparation
for this I'd like to think that this is
gonna be okay I mean it's just a guy
playing around in my mouth Brian I can't
the teeth become discolored due to many
different reasons it could be diet you
know drinking too much one coke or
smoking the two kinds that we offer in
our office we do a Zoom Whitening which
is mostly hydrogen peroxide in it and
hydrogen peroxide is basically bleach
you're smiling you're like thinking oh
this is painful oh I'm glad I'm not
doing that one then they're sensational
one that we use in our office doesn't
have any other kind of chemicals to help
accelerate their process so it's a much
smoother process for the patient our
blinding is my smile gonna be like
that's what I'm gonna be rocking notice
so we're gonna start with two of you uh
who's gonna go first do we know okay you
have a cool room back there for the boys
there's also a hoverboard back there
right there is I'm gonna ride the [ __ ]
of that I hover board while wearing that
hat
so Macey and I are both gonna be doing
the chemical process I think my teeth
are already kind of white but I'm pretty
excited to make them like super white
yeah you look like you're from the
future how do you like it - uh we made
it just for you just this looks relaxing
I would love to just do this at home on
a Saturday by myself that's relaxing
yeah everyone keeps talking about how
it's about to hurt so like I have no
idea what I'm really in for I can't
imagine what would be doing for an hour
and a half shell a hoverboard with a
viking helmet or a pimp hat it's great
this is what I want every time I come to
the orthodontist yeah
the first to like phases was like
totally fine I was relaxed everything
was great there was just a sharp
shooting pain I'm just on my bottom
teeth don't worry you'd all be over soon
it'll be fine you know - the fact that
Ryan is trying to put his nasty hot air
in my face everything else is great so
who's here who's your favorite who's
your favorite friend
that's the wrong answer the head of this
lamp is gonna go right on top right just
gonna beam you up we thought all you do
is put down their mouth wait wait
put the shades on so it's cool little
shades no chemicals you know nothing
unnatural this is all natural baby
what about 30 minutes you see you on the
other side yeah sleep with one eye open
I didn't realize like how much of a
discrepancy away
what are you looking at no one's gonna
help you I hope you know that no one's
coming for the sharpies mm-hmm got
anything to say oh nothing
I am thought it was cute to blow hot air
in my face so I think it would be cute
to give Ryan a little I appreciate Ryan
so much
for the most part it wasn't that bad I
had I felt it a little bit it was a
little sensitive but for the most part I
don't think my teeth are that sensitive
like it didn't really hurt it would come
in wave so I'd be like fine and then all
of a sudden it would just see this like
really intense pain no no aches no pains
very quick I just had a weird little
gelatin thing in my mouth my jaw got
kind of tired after a while but that was
it very soothing very relaxing is
basically just a nap the treatment was
great I just fit into a mouthpiece like
Steph Curry it was all over I never
pictured myself having no a Sons of
Anarchy style tattoo of the word penis
on my neck we have like amazingly white
teeth right now so I also think that if
you really want super white teeth this
would be the way to go so it's like no
pain no gain it depends on like you know
how committed you are to having
whitening it essentially